في نوفمبر الماضي وصل عدد سكان العالم الى
8 مليارات للسماء وقتها خرجت تحضيرات من
عدم القدره على توفير احتاج احتياجاتهم من
طاقه وغذاء على الجانب الاخر تفاءل اخرون
بهذه الزياده فكل ما زاد العدد زادت
الاقدام وارتفع استهلاك الاحذيه فرغم
الازمه الاقتصاديه كشفت منصه انتكس بوكس
الامريكيه نسوق الاحذيه سيصل الى 220
مليار دولار عام 2030 هذه زياده لا تشجعها
عوامل قد تعتقدها بسيطه لكن تاثيرها كبير
جدا على هذا السوق متابع معاكي لميس
يحتقطع الاحذيه الرياضيه القسم الاكبر
للسوق العالمي للاحذيه كونها مريحه من جهه
وايضا زلت الاهتمام بمودعات الصحه
واللياقه البدنيه منصه اندكس بوكس كشفت ان
علامه نايكي بمفردها في العام 2019 على
31.6% من السوق فيما حصل العلامه
الالمانيه اديداس على 21.7% اذا السوق
محتكر من الشركات الكبيره لكن لماذا لان
تكاليفه عاليه وتتوزع على غرفه تشغيل
المصانع البحث والتطوير الترويج والتسويق
وهذا ما يفسر صعوب الدخول وافدين جدد
الابحا تشير الى ان مازال من التوسع في
السنوات القادمه بدعوه عوامل متعدده
ابرازها زياده عدد السكان وارتفاع متوسطه
الدخل الفردي بالاضافه الى نمو التجاره
الالكترونيه التي ستسمح بالاصول الى
مستهلكين من جميع انحاء العالم
النسائيه بسرعه اكبر من سوق الاحذيه وذلك
بسبب الارتفاع المستمر في اعداد النساء
التي تدخلوا سوق العمل
[موسيقى]
سالنا الناس لماذا تنفق الفتيات اموالا
طائله على الاحذيه الرياضيه الفاخره
صبحكم الله بالخير اهلا وسهلا فيكم
مشاهدينا احدثكم من احد المجمعات التجاريه
بالرياض واللي يتواجد فيه اغلب البراندات
العالميه سؤالنا اليوم موجه للشباب
والفتيات والسؤال ليش برايك الشباب او
الفتيات يقتلون الاحذيه الغاليه راح ناخذ
اراهم في هذا المكان خليكم معنا
[موسيقى]
حذاء
التكلفه عشان يكون يعني مرتاح سوا رياضي
بيكون يعني بيشتغلوا في الرياضيات
طول معك عمر افضل جوده هتكون عاليه فوق
كذا مريحه
[موسيقى]
النفس وبعدين في شو اسمه جزم مالها جوده
رخيصه مالها جوده
بس شو اسم الغاليه له جوده وحلوه بالنسبه
لي افضل المتوسطه السعر
لي شيء عادي بس بعد سنه وسنتين خلاص ما
اشوف شيء حلو
فالبران صراحه 10 سنوات انت مرتاح قسمين
قسم الاول اللي يشتري البراند نفسه ما هم
الجوده ولا شيء وبس يبغى انه يمتلك شيء
القسم الثاني
بتقدر تتاكد من الكل تتبعها ممتاز بتقدر
تاكد انه حتى ما تتلف معك مع الزمن بس
تبعها هي همم راحت الحذاء نفسه يعني